I was wondering if you can comment on
a idea and notion that comes up often in
conversations about
this of why can't other nations in the
region take in uh Palestinian refugees
so I think that we have to tackle what's
implied by that at multiple levels and I
actually want to walk back you know I I
was listening to Nikki Haley when she uh
said in one of her interviews you know
and why is it that you think no one
wants to take the Palestinians in and
she had like this
deeply uh disturbing laugh to it uh or
Ben Shapiro when he uh said uh Israelis
like to build and Arabs like to bomb
crap and live in their sewage uh or um
you know why is it that no one wants to
govern the Palestinians suggesting that
Palestinians are ungovernable and
uh not fit to bring into your countries
and that's why they're being turned away
you know who else faced that bigotry
Jews trying to escape the Holocaust
1939 300,000 Germans applied for Refuge
here in the United States I think only
about
10,000 uh were allowed in and uh we also
turned away ships of Jews that were
seeking Refuge here in the United States
on what basis that they were a national
security
threat and could not be trusted they
could not be taken
in that's the same bigotry that's
driving this and I want you to think
about it you know from that perspective
How Deeply offensive that is when you
have millions of Palestinians in
diaspora where have Palestinians caused
trouble where they've gone everywhere
Palestinians are they have overcome
significant hurdles to become scientists
and
doctors and to grow themselves and to
grow the places that they're in we have
Palestinians that have been displaced
all over the world caused issues for
people right so it's both racist and
factually
incorrect that's not the right question
that should be asked the question that
should be asked are why are these people
driven from their homes not why won't
other people around them open their
homes to them and so I'll I'll just
share with you that even on a personal
level you know it's it's really
interesting because uh uh sometimes on
on Twitter or wherever it is it'll be
like go back home right why don't you go
back home and I'm sitting there thinking
to myself like
sure you know my parents were driven
from their homes yeah sure I was born in
this country as a consequence of bad
policy now I embrace my complicated
identity in that regard and I hope to be
productive as an American but I am a
Palestinian and Palestinians in diaspora
that have been fortunate enough to have
the ability uh to build and to overcome
circumstances should not be an excuse
for eliminating the Palestinians that
remain in their homes under that that
torment so uh this bigotry is not new um
unfortunately its manifestation is ugly
and um you know we have to push back on
it whenever it shows itself no matter
who it's being spoken
about how difficult has it been for
people in Gaza to
flee I mean they're blockaded from all
directions there is nowhere for people
in Gaza to go they cannot get out and um
you know the reality is is that they
don't want to leave they do not want to
leave the Palestinian people people want
to live in their land in their
homes and to continue to produce you
know uh an extension of the beautiful
culture and Legacy that was handed to
them they don't want to leave in fact
those that have fled for whatever reason
or have been able to get out for medical
treatment or because they have some sort
of citizenship in other countries all
they're talking about is going back and
rebuilding you can't bomb Palestine out
of our hearts you cannot starve
Palestine out of our hearts I think
that's a critical mistake that Israel is
making and it thinks that if it destroys
Gaza enough if it wipes out all the
buildings that people will never want to
come back we don't want to go anywhere
as a Palestinian people you know in a
way that would remove us from our homes
the Palestinian people are proud people
yeah you've met a lot of them right when
you sat with uh Muhammad Kor people in
East Jerusalem what those people have
been subjected to you know the
harassment like think about the the the
tenacity and the character that it takes
to still try to walk back into your home
after an intruder has been brought in by
the state that's sitting in your living
room that is pushing you around and
you're saying I'm not leaving my home
this is literally what's been happening
in East
Jerusalem and we're not going anywhere I
think those of us that are in diaspora
Palestine is not leaving our hearts and
those of us that are still there are not
leaving their land and the world has to
make the occupier more accountable not
tell the occupied how to cope do you
ever imagine that if your
family did not flee and you were now
living in in say in
Gaza what you would be
doing I think
about what could have been all the
time you know I actually mentioned this
in the first uh DC
protest that I remember getting a
notification a news
notification um just prior to
October with my name in it you know so I
always get these notifications right if
my name's been mentioned in an article
and so oh your name's been mentioned in
an article and it was a 16-year-old alar
man who was murdered in the
Westbank he literally had my name I held
up his picture and I realized that could
have been
me so I
think of why God chose me to not be
there and hopefully him
choosing all of us that are not there to
be for the those that are still there to
be their voices I'm grateful and I'm
also in pain I'm grateful for the
opportunity to be able to speak on their
behalf but I'm also guilty that they
have to bear the brunt of this evil
hatred that unfortunately displaced our
parents in the first
place
that